[Music]
I you know even the term political
correctness at this point I feel like
has been compromised has been diluted
and means different things to different
people in a way that's like
counterproductive I would vote to retire
the term entirely I guess where I fall
is on one hand if you are whining about
the way that political correctness and
some culture of respect prevents you
from being an asshole
then you're an asshole you know if the
political correctness of the world stops
you impinges your freedom of speech and
prevent you from being misogynistic
homophobic racist then fuck you
basically I guess that's ultimately
where I fall on it I don't really know
any artists any creative folks who feel
like some restrictive culture is
preventing them from doing their art you
know the people I see are flourishing in
this space I think respect is important
I think calling people by the words and
the names and the pronouns that they
choose for themselves is critical
there's no reason in any sense to do
otherwise that I can think of but I feel
like the the term itself you know as far
back as the 90s was being bandied about
in this spirit of mockery and you know I
remember books being published like you
know the politically correct handbook
and you know like just just take you to
a level of absurdity you know people of
various marginalized discriminated
against groups were claiming ownership
of the words used to describe them was
taken and satirized and made absurd by
the right a group of people who are not
known for their sense of humor and you
know it became kind of a battering ram
like oh you know we can't say blah blah
blah and people you know like well you
can't say short anymore you have to say
vertically challenged you know and it
was very deliberate I mean it was part
of the war around language which is a
very critical part of political
discourse the control of terminology is
really really important in the way that
people's views are shaped and it's
something that the write has had
us a lock-on surprisingly for a pretty
long time you know pro-life sounds good
but isn't but the way that the words and
the phrases in the terminology shape the
debate is really critical so you know
that the term in my mind goes back to
that and yeah at this point I think we
could probably put it to death and come
up with something better
[Music]
you